when you see that word continuously  you're thinking about this formula here  the PERT formula a equals P the  principle what you put in E which is our  natural base E which is two point seven  1 approximately R is the rate okay of  growth or interest rate okay as a  decimal and then T is the time usually  in years so what we're going to do is  look at a couple examples problems and  how to work with this formula we're  starting off with 1,000 years our base  and we're raising it to the point zero  two times seven so let's go ahead and do  that in the calculator let's see what we  get so you're starting with a thousand e  to the point O two times seven okay so  that's one thousand one hundred fifty  point two seven one one five zero point  two seven so that includes the original  thousand plus you know the amount of  growth or the the interest earned  okay the next